welcome to this video playing mr.
galettes x mr. Collett sex with that
Nicole I Mickelson okay um Swedish I'm
sorry what is this probably Danish right
yeah it's got a spanish flag yep I'm
going for your form part of the opening
challenge and them yeah he's taking time
out there hmm yep maybe went for a five
minute game and now yeah what to do
against the French actually I play the
turusch normally when i get to the
French
hmm
talaash is more manageable let's say
than 93 so let's see going for a little
trick line here that I know 90 of six
Bishop d7 but it's not falling for that
so let's just continue um castles
probably i don't really know that the
the Rubenstein variation what really you
can afford that that is risky i can even
take on the form right away so let's
let's just do that what is this reply to
that night 95 or what I dealt it take
first thing later we takes default
Bishop e7 wins the rook they also Bishop
e7 Bishop d6s answered by night f5 it is
also answered by 905 but I wonders
there's something better now this is
good it's just great let's do that so um
can I already kill him with 97 sorry
97 King the chicken before check he's
going back Queen f5 Knight f6 just
towards just about her walls so okay so
then just this one g6 he has to do and
then Bishop g5 is another temple more
show g5g takes a five Queen f5 just wins
Knight f6 queen age four also it's
immediately over so he has to move the
Queen I think notice this one really
should be five check Bishop age six is
also not a bad move okay but if I check
him there King King age eight Wow Bishop
age 6
there should a six rope g8 I can at
least win the exchange so it's not it's
not them it's not bad Bishop g7
checkmate so the group GA this is
mandatory and I can at least take g8 now
and just one that says something better
there because it looks completely
completely bonkers they're not probably
not okay I'm taking the exchange cannot
take a five year it's made on g7 you can
you take the night maybe from probably
not
now I cannot take the night am sorry
move the night or something like that no
i don't i don't really see a move maybe
he has to check with the king and i have
Quincy for check and then Queen to f7
that's also over yeah when you form the
way to shorten your games Queen gen4
check and Queen f7 and that's it I think
black resigns yeah if I've was really i
mean sorry I'm not not what the sound
unfriendly or anything if I've is really
insane I mean you cannot really delay
your development that much it looks
really bad okay night XD for Islam most
obvious move probably this right it's
also the computer suggestion so I'm
taking not to get the porn back but to
get the Knight to f5 it opened the
position of the engine gives 95 as a
relatively best reply than 91 this is
what I was thinking that I have to do
this he cannot take me made and I'm
keeping here this night Can Can Has
discoveries and I was thinking something
like this is probably happening okay I
didn't calculate further but my
development is so excellent okay you
went here night there that looks good
here and from here it's interesting 91
sorry rook t1 is the computer is there a
problem with this mission g5 k f6 losses
due to what I played ok he has to go as
to play a queen move and this is not the
engine is not giving me a direct win but
it might be a matter of
um depth left of search because this
check is definitely strong Queen a
choice the most obvious move they're
taking is losing immediately and that
that's simply impossible and while i'm
in checking with with all the pieces
they are Queen e6 is the computer line
night back with a good position for
Bishop age six possibly computer gives
plus one for whatever that's worth yeah
but this is just winning right bishop h6
route g8 is only move Bishop g7 mate is
the it's the big thing so takes and now
Knight b6 yeah i was thinking at night
move maybe but i can go back Bishop
takes and this and i'm just an exchange
of with an ok position so that it's the
best check I didn't play that to rub it
in Queen f7 does winner to resign should
I honey had to made already this is
already it's also made right yeah I saw
that this is mating she said it was much
simpler okay yeah I hope you like that
thanks for watching